[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
true
[Music]
hmm
hello everyone i'm kazunori yamauchi
producer of the gran turismo series
today i'm here to give you an update on
our latest game gran turismo 7 releasing
march 4th 2022.
over its 25 year history the gran
turismo series has demonstrated a
serious love and respect for cars
what's more gran turismo 7 represents
the 25th anniversary of the series
gran turismo 7 will represent the
pinnacle of the gt journey we think of
it as our most complete gt to date
we have designed gt7 so that those who
have never come into contact with
automotive culture until now can really
get to know the deep rich world of cars
our aim was to create a driving
simulator that all players can enjoy
whether you're a hardcore gran turismo
fan or brand new to the series
i think gran turismo 7 will be enjoyable
for everyone
the history of cars is long and the
world of cars is massive with lots of
attractive cars contained within
[Music]
for gt7 we have prepared over 400 cars
from automobile brands around the world
we've also prepared 34 locations from
around the globe with over 90 layouts
and more tracks and cars will be added
in future online updates
[Music]
now let's take a closer look at the gt7
player experience
our inspiration here was to create a
paradise almost a vacation resort that
celebrates car culture
[Music]
when you begin the campaign you'll use
provided in-game credits to purchase a
compact car
[Music]
you'll then progress through the
campaign by participating in races
unlocking new cars and by tuning and
upgrading your vehicles for better
performance
this is ultimately the classic gt
campaign mode but gt7 has more to offer
[Music]
one new feature is the gran turismo cafe
this will be the center of the map in
gran turismo 7.
here at the cafe players will be given a
car collection
[Music]
menu complete each menu by winning races
and championships while exploring this
car resort
[Music]
sometimes the people who actually
designed those cars will appear to talk
about the design in person
by completing menus for a variety of car
collections at the cafe players would
naturally come into contact with the
history of cars and the culture behind
them
[Music]
brand central is a shopping mall where a
player can purchase new cars
here players can purchase roughly 300
car models from 2001 and
later automotive manufacturers from
around the world have assembled here
[Music]
not only are there showrooms for
purchasing cars there's also a museum
for each manufacturer where you can
learn about the history of individual
brands
this is a museum of porsche
[Music]
and it begins with the birth of dr
ferdinand porsche establishing his own
design firm
[Music]
gran turismo 7 also houses a world of
used cars
at the used car dealer players can
purchase cars for more affordable prices
however some very popular used cars may
be sold at an even higher price than
when they originally came out
these include the japanese sports cars
of the 90s that are seeing a big boom in
popularity worldwide
this car lineup will be updated and
changed slightly every day
[Music]
certain iconic cars have marked their
names in the history books even after
100 years their allure will never fade
the legendary car dealership specializes
in these types of famous vehicles
[Music]
in the world circuit you'll have access
to a variety of tracks
at launch gt7 will feature 34 locations
and over 90 layouts
this includes real world and fantasy
circuits
[Music]
legendary fantasy tracks from past gt
games such as trial mountain deep forest
and high speed ring return for gt7 with
stunning modern visuals
[Music]
there are various races and
championships hosted at each track
[Music]
[Applause]
and the circuit experience activity can
help you learn these tracks
[Music]
in the custom race mode you can combine
things like weather conditions and ai
cars of your choice to create
personalized races
[Music]
grand is most well known for its license
tests
many people look back and remember how
hard they tried to achieve gold results
in this mode
naturally gt7 includes license tests
where you can learn driving techniques
from the ground up
here there are many short mini games
that teach you these skills
mission races is where you'll find
unique events beyond typical races and
time trials
[Music]
for example here's drag racing
you'll need to tune your car for more
power
while also remembering the importance of
throttle control from a standing start
[Music]
there are also drift trials where
players compete using their drifting
techniques
there are several ways to play and
interact with other players in gt7
first there is a two-player split screen
that you can play together in your
living room with family and friends
[Music]
so
[Music]
second there are lobbies and meeting
places that you can enjoy with your
friends online
[Music]
finally in sport mode you can enjoy
serious racing with players all over the
world
[Music]
hello
[Music]
completely recreating beautiful cars is
the essence of the gran turismo series
the playstation 5 version of gt7
features photorealistic graphics using
ray tracing
ray tracing aims to more accurately
depict lighting and reflections
but the application that is most suited
for may actually be in the expression of
cars
[Music]
this is because the shiny surfaces of
cars reflect the world around them
[Music]
with ray tracing the graphics of gran
turismo make a jump into the next
dimension
[Music]
[Music]
the color of the skies and the shape of
the clouds you see every day are
determined by the energy of the sun the
earth itself and the condition of the
atmosphere that surrounds it
if you look at on a global scale air
containing moisture from the oceans
flows into the continents that air is
warmed by the earth's surface heated by
the sun which produces ascending air
currents
the air containing moisture will
continue to rise in altitude due to this
current and once at a certain altitude
and temperature creates the clouds you
see in the sky
in gt7 we have simulated the process of
how these clouds are formed
based on a vast amount of meteorological
data temperatures humidity and air
pressure specific to each region
skies in japan will change like they do
in japan and skies in california will
change as they do in california
the gran turismo series has always
placed an importance on starlit skies at
night
in gt7 we have aimed for an even higher
quality of expression
starry sky skies seen in specific
locations at certain dates and times
will be drawn using a simulation that
includes not just stars but even planets
the moon will rise and set in the same
way that the sun rises and sets
the color of the stars will change
depending on whether the atmosphere is
clear or hazy
time changes and weather simulations are
expressed in the scenery and light
these factors can affect atmospheric and
surface temperatures
by doing so affect the tire grip engine
power and strength of the slipstream
effect
integrating with the automotive physics
simulation
it rains and the surface becomes wet
puddles form in locations that are prone
to them
the rain ends
and the surface starts to dry from the
areas that tend to dry first
the areas with puddles will remain wet
the longest
and these kinds of changes will occur
naturally
one simple example of this weather
simulation is a rain cloud radar that
many players will be familiar with
players can look at this display and
predict the coming weather to a certain
extent
on a huge circuit like the nurburgring
it can rain on one part of the track
while being sunny on a different section
gran turismo is a real driving simulator
but we always place the same level of
importance in being able to watch your
driving in a replay as we have with the
fun of driving
this high quality replay mode is also
present in gt7
[Music]
foreign
we have developed a new music replay
that dynamically generates a replay
camera to match the background music
[Music]
unlike pass replay modes where the
cameras were fixed on the track
camera positions and image cuts are now
generated randomly every time to match
the music
allowing you to enjoy a different camera
replay every time you run it back
[Music]
now let's show you part of the music
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
scapes offers a new world of photography
and is a mode where you can travel the
world with your favorite car
[Music]
you can place the car of your choice in
over 2500 spots around the globe
[Music]
and take cutting-edge hdr photos
[Music]
by combining true to life light
information with photo effects this mode
allows high level photographic
expressions that are mostly impossible
in real life photography
[Music]
the race photo mode allows you to
photograph races you've participated in
going to a real circuit to take
photographs is a lot of work but in gt7
you can photograph dynamic beautiful
shots that even professional
photographers would struggle to take
with much greater ease
[Music]
grand freezmo 7 is also a creative tool
our players can use to produce various
content
replays
photographs taken in game livery designs
and more
[Music]
the showcase is a place where this
content can be shared for other players
to download
[Music]
finally please settle in for a look at
some new gran turismo 7 gameplay
our closing segment shows two new
features added to gran turismo 7.
the music rally where you enjoy music
while you drive
and the music replay that syncs replays
to music
these are all real-time images captured
on the playstation 5 console
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stuck in this place
[Music]
just
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for watching
see you on the track on march 4th 2022
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
playstation